zurück bei viertel nach acht schön dass
Sie bei uns sind zwei Kinder haben ein
Kind ermordet das ist die Nachricht des
heutigen Tages die Deutschland viele
Fragen stellen ist die Deutschland
trauern lässt und über dieses Thema
müssen wir hier sprechen gleichzeitig
aber auch darüber dass es immer mehr
Gewalt hatten in Deutschland gibt woran
liegt das wir wollen dieser Sache immer
mehr jetzt auf den Grund gehen unser
Chefreporter Frank Schneider ist hier
bei uns im Studio Frank und du hast
viele Zahlen uns mitgebracht wir wollen
uns ganz allgemein mit dem Thema
Gewalttaten vor allem mit Messern hier
in dieser Sendung einmal nähern und du
sagst da müssen wir endlich aufwachen
denn es werden immer mehr deine Zeit
dein Thema ja genau das ist ein großes
Problem und was auch viele Innenminister
beruhigt wir haben die ersten Zahlen
jetzt am Sonntag Westfalen und auch von
der Bundespolizei und ich will einfach
mal ein paar Zahlen Vorlesen damit man
es einfach auch mal wirklich plastisch
sieht die haupttaten sind in diesem Jahr
also im letzten Jahr natürlich aber in
diesem Jahr sind die Zahlen
veröffentlicht worden
37 Prozent nach oben gegangen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Körperverletzungen
24 Prozent Mord und Totschlag 23 Prozent
wir hatten in der Stadt wie Essen allein
im letzten Jahr 275 Messerangriffe die
Bundespolizei sagt auch jeden Tag ein
Messerangriff den Zügen in Bahnhöfen und
erschreckend ist besonders auch und das
passt ja leider auf dramatische Weise zu
dem Fall aus Freudenberg es ist eben so
dass die Kinder und Jugendlichen
überproportional beteiligt sind wir
haben bei 500.000 Tatverdächtige
Nordrhein-Westfalen 100.000 also jeder
fünfte unter 21 und davon noch mal 20%
unter 14 also Kinder straf unmündige
Kinder und auch da zum Beispiel eine
Zahl aus Essen in Essen wohnen im
letzten Jahr 936 kinderstraffällig man
kann auch außer mit dem Jugendamt dem
überhaupt nicht begegnen und ich glaube
wir haben ja gerade über Corona
diskutiert auch Corona hat er sicherlich
eine Rolle gespielt wir haben immer
gehört von überfüllten Kinder und
Jugendpsychiatrie und ich glaube dass
das auch mit eine Folge ist dieser Zeit
Kinder nicht in der Schule keine
sozialen Kontakte Konflikte konnten
nicht ge erklärt werden und ich glaube
da muss ganz ganz dringend was passieren
und eben nicht nur von Polizei und
Justiz sondern eben auch von
Sozialarbeitern Kinder töten Kinder das
ist so ein brutales Thema das so im
Herzen weh tut schade dass unser
Psychiater uns verlassen hat und dann
möchte natürlich auch gerne über die
Hintergründe sprechen Frank wie erklärst
du dir auch diesen generellen Anstieg
die Zahlen die du uns mitgebracht hast
was sind die Hintergründe woher kommen
diese erschreckenden Zahlen ja da gibt
es leider nicht so diese diesen einen
Grund das ist sehr sehr viel steht ich
habe so mit Corona angesprochen zum
anderen kommt auch dazu junge Menschen
sind heute gar nicht mehr so in der Lage
Konfliktlösung zu betreiben die haben
gar nicht mehr die Möglichkeit Konflikte
vernünftig zu klären es ist nicht wie
früher in der Schule da ging man nach
Hause und hatte erstmal Distanz heute
durch Social Media sondern im
permanenten Konflikt im permanenter
Kommunikation aber auch negativer
Kommunikation es entstehen
Drucksituationen dazu kommt auf der
Straße es wird immer mehr in Gruppen
tritt man auf man will auch Messer als
männlichkeitssymbol teilweise durch
Migration verwende dann öffnen sich
andere um sich zu schützen und dass ein
riesengroßes Problem denn wenn man ein
Messer dabei hat dann setzt man es eben
auch im schlimmsten Fall ein und viele
unterschätzen dass ein Messerstich eben
tödlich sein kann auch schon den
Oberschenkel da wird eine Arterie
verletzt oder ähnliches und dann ist
dieser Stich eben tödlich und ich glaube
das ist eine Entwicklung da muss einfach
die Politik massiv begegnen und wie
gesagt das ist nicht nur ein
polizeiliches Thema oder das Justiz
gerade bei straf-univer Justiz machen
die kann ja gar nichts machen ich glaube
das sind Schulen gefordert da ist sind
Sozialarbeiter von Jugendämter gefordert
Städte sofort Kommunen und alle müssen
dadurch an einem Strang ziehen denn es
ist eine dramatische Entwicklung und nur
zu sagen naja nach Corona die sind
wieder mehr draußen die Zahlen gehen
hoch das hilft nicht denn die Zahlen die
haben sich teilweise verdoppelt auch auf
Spielplätzen gibt es jedes Jahr tausende
von Straftaten es gibt sie auf dem
Schulweg auf dem Schulhof und das sind
Zahlen die sind deutlich höher als vor
Corona das zeigt das ist eine insgesamt
Entwicklung der jetzt unbedingt sofort
begegnet werden
in der Tasche dazu wird auch oft
imiert schon was einmal ein Beispiel
rausgesucht von einem Lied von einem
sorgen den hören Kinder und Jugendliche
mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag darauf
und runter das sind kann man befürchten
dann Vorbilder für manche Kinder und
manche Jugendliche haben einmal rein
und deswegen nehmen sie mir wieder mein
Geld das sieht ein Schwert oder
gleichschenkt und ich habe gar keinen
Bock mich hin und Schutz zu waschen
dicker alle meine Jungs kann man
bisschen Knast kein Grund nicht zu
lachen keiner von euch schafft es gar
Simon tot zu machen
im Gefängnis aber produziert auch die
ein oder anderen Hits heißt Kinder und
Jugendliche kaufen es einfach auch und
nehmen sich vielleicht so ein Rapper
auch als Vorbild und auch seine Texte
sind für sie aber doch mehr Realität
gerade eben haben wir gehört ganz klar
die Politik darf da nicht die Augen
verschließen verschießt die Politik so
oft auch die Augen vor dem Tätern dass
man nicht zu sehr darüber sprechen will
das kommt die politische Antwort das ist
eine so umfassende Sache die kann man
nicht auf eines fokussieren kann wenn
sie bei der Situation anfangen das ist
schon passiert ist also bei den
repressiven Maßnahmen ja klar dann muss
man einmal schauen ob
Staatsanwaltschaften oft oder zu oft
einstellen die sind weisungsgebunden das
kann ein Minister Justizminister
bestimmen das ist die eine Sache vor
allem gerade in Bezug auch auf
Rettungskräfte auf die blaulichtfamilie
Royal in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat das
gefordert auch gemacht damit alles zur
Anlage gebracht das ist dann wenn es
passiert ist
das kann abschreckend sein muss es auch
sein und das muss auch entsprechend ja
mit einer Strafe versehen sein die weh
tut es muss am klar sein jetzt geht es
aber entscheidender darum was passiert
denn vorher und da gehört zunächst
einmal dazu
dass man mehr Polizei auf die Straße
bringt das ist in jedem Bundesland ein
riesen Problem und das war es die ganzen
Jahre hinweg jetzt hat man mal 5000
Bundespolizisten mehr eingestellt sie
wissen selbst wie im Moment bei der
Frage der der Flüchtlingsbewegungen
schon die Außengrenzen nicht geschützt
werden können wie wollen Sie das
Darstellen sie brauchen mehr Personal
das muss auch besser geschult sein und
sie müssen auch da sein und weil das
nicht reicht mit mehr Personal müssen
Sie mehr Videoüberwachung zulassen das
ist selbstverständlich ich frag mich
immer wovor habe ich Angst wenn ich an
einem Bahnhof vorbei laufe dass mich da
einer filmt wenn ich das weiß dass er
mich filmt und wenn ich weiß dass das
nach einer gewissen Zeit vernichten muss
also das entscheidende dann kann mir das
doch egal sein also das sind die zweiten
Maßnahmen und die dritte viel
entscheidendere ja es ist eine
gesellschaftspolitische Problem
Informatik Eltern scheinen sich nicht
mehr ausreichen damit zu befassen was
ihre Kinder tun und wenn sie es tun weiß
ich auch nicht ob Kinder nicht in
anderen Umfeldern beispielsweise in der
Schule und sonst wo im übrigen fällt ja
viel zu viel Unterricht auch aus da kann
man auch noch viele andere Dinge tun
sich dort kommunikativ in eine Richtung
bewegen die Gewaltverherrlichung
mitbringt wir haben auch eine ganz
andere Situation wenn ich mir alleine
meine Kinder anschaut die sind jetzt
allerdings auch schon 22 und 20 die
spielen heute spiele das hat also wir
haben früher auch Spiele gespielt auf
der Straße heute sind die am Computer ja
so also ich will das jetzt nicht falsch
verstanden wir sind alle okay kann man
alles tun aber man muss natürlich dann
auch schauen was wird da gespielt wer
lässt das zu und wer kontrolliert was da
gespielt wird bei der Musik kann ich
Ihnen nur eines sagen
ich persönlich habe nichts gegen Rap ich
höre nur Heavy Metal aber das kann man
ja auch hören nur wenn es solche verwalt
gewaltverherrlichten Titel gibt mit
diesen Texten dann finde ich gehören die
außenprogramm das kann nicht sein dass
wir sowas einfach auch noch als Kunst
oder Musik mit zulassen wenn es solche
Dinge gibt da muss man Strick da dran
aber Einsatz zu sagen wir diskutieren in
Deutschland über Leila ob das
möglicherweise jugendgefährdend ist
alles ganz schrecklich und solche Lieder
dürfen dann auf den Markt und das ist
etwas was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe
auch gefährlich sein man kann leider ja
doof wenn man muss es eben auch nicht
hören aber das ist keine Musik die
Menschen haben sondern solche Musik und
da wird Gewalt absolut verherrlicht und
da ist es ja auch toll wenn man eben im
Knast gesessen aber man ist gangster
rapper man ist was und das ist leider
Gottes für ganz viele junge Menschen die
teilweise auch gesellschaftlich Abgang
sind abgehängt sind die gar nicht wissen
wohin geht die Reise für mich dann
suchen Sie sich diese Idole und träumen
davon irgendwann auch so ein cooler oder
nicht vermeiden nicht verhindern das ist
so weil die Menschen schon immer gab
aber das werden einfach viel zu viele
Kinder die falschen Vorbilder sollte man
die Lieder verbieten sollte man mehr
Kameras aufstellen sind hier Lösungen
für sie dabei kann ich mein Vater nicht
fragen der schon lange gestorben ob ich
damals die falschen Vorbilder gehabt
habe auch die Idee zum Beispiel
irgendwelche heutzutage noch
irgendwelche Lieder zu verbieten ich
weiß nicht also es gibt ja immer noch
diese Zentralstelle zur Prüfung
jugendgefährdender Schriften
es gibt eigentlich immer so die
Motivation dass das dann besonders
interessant wird und Leila hätte glaube
ich kein Mensch interessiert
Diskussion gegeben hätte aber ähm die
Sänger haben sich gefreut glaube ich
eine jugendlicheren heiße hieß sie ich
kann mich erinnern ich habe darüber sehr
viele Talkshow Rezension damals
geschrieben und er hat mir exakt
dieselbe Diskussion 1:1 dieselbe
Diskussion steigende Zahlen da ging es
dann so gegen dieses gegen diese
liberale Vorstellung von von Strafe
nämlich gar nicht zu straffen und jetzt
frage ich mich für mich in diese ganzen
zehn Jahren was hat sich dort geändert
also ich glaube zum Beispiel sehr viele
Gerichte heute nicht mehr diese Larifari
Haltung haben die versuchen auch die
Zeiten zu verkürzen und so weiter das
hat natürlich besser geworden ja das
muss man erstmal und dann könnte man ja
dann nachvollziehen so wie sie das auch
versucht haben zu schildern was ist
eigentlich jetzt im Laufe dieser 10-15
Jahre noch dazu gekommen an Problemen
und natürlich verändert sich auch die
Lebenswelt von Jugendlichen merke ich
bei meinen eigenen Kindern also ich habe
vier davon und natürlich spielen die
antibi alle Spiele ich habe nicht mit
Videospielen gespielt weil äh zu meiner
Zeit gab sie noch gar nicht also aber
das ist eine Situation daran kann man
nichts ändern nein aber was woran wir
etwas ändern können das ist natürlich
schon z.B eine Situation dass das
jugendliche und in Schulen funktionieren
das Kindergärten funktionieren und und
ganz plastisches Beispiel was ich Ihnen
sagen erzählen kann
gibt's zum Beispiel so eine Gruppe von
jungen
vegan die vom Jugendamt von der
Jugendhilfe betreut werden ja die warten
sechs Monate darauf dass sie überhaupt
beschult werden ja klar gibt es keine
Schule für die was machen sie die ganze
Zeit die musste in irgendeiner Form dann
gehen die Betreuer mit den einem Mann
der Woche Fußball spielen und kümmern
sich wirklich um die aber selbst so
etwas Elementares wie zum Beispiel
Schulunterricht findet dann nicht statt
und ich weiß nicht wie das hier in
Berlin wie das hier in Berlin ist ich
wohne hier in der Westfälischen Provinz
der funktioniert das vielleicht noch
besser aber wenn wir solche elementaren
Dinge nicht hinbekommen ja dann brauchen
wir über diesen ganzen anderen Kram
glaube ich erstmal gar nicht zu reden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie